It's frightening to think about how many people
go missing each year.
Approximately 1,600 individuals mysteriously
vanish each year in national parks alone.
One moment they're there, making their way
down a hiking trail or stopping for a granola
bar by a lake,
and the next, they're gone.
Missing people are an unfortunate fact of
life, one we all just try to put out of our
minds as we silently hope we, and those we
know and love,
will be fortunate enough to avoid joining
the ranks of the lost.
But some places, some very strange, obscure
places, nestled in the quiet countryside and
tucked away under blankets of fog,
lose so many people that it becomes, well,
anomalous.
One particular town, a seemingly innocuous
place with a thriving tourism industry was
the site of so many unexplained disappearances
that it drew the attention of The SCP Foundation.
They dispatched a team to enter the town,
to gather as many facts and figures as they
could,
and to see what exactly had become of these
missing people.
Leading this team was none other than the
sometimes fearless, often shameless, Dr. Jack
Bright.
How did the infamous Dr. Bright get here?
Well, for many employees of the SCP Foundation,
leading a task force to investigate a new
potentially anomalous location would be a
promotion,
or a welcome diversion from yet another round
of testing to see if maybe something will
finally destroy SCP-682.
But in this particular case, it was a matter
of discipline.
After Dr. Bright was caught giving SCP-999
a triple-shot of espresso, "just to see what
would happen,"
he was assigned to field work as part of his
punishment.
For the record, what happened was SCP-999
ricocheting off of the walls at such high
speed and intensity
that it broke several windows, damaged the
ceiling, and knocked out the power for half
of the Site.
And, so, Dr. Bright found himself with a task
force of Foundation operatives trudging reluctantly
through beautiful but boring rural New England,
toward the town of interest.
As he drove down the winding road, grumbling
to himself and wishing he could be anywhere
else,
he spotted the sign marking their intended
destination: "Welcome to Silent Hill."
Up ahead, a thick fog rolling off the lake
covered the town in a dim gray blur.
He couldn't make out anything through the
unnaturally dense haze.
He squinted and turned on the high beams,
but the light did nothing to cut through the
fog,
bouncing off of it like a billowing curtain
of white.
Just as they passed the sign, the van began
to slow rapidly, its engine sputtering and
grinding as the vehicle skidded to a sudden
stop.
"Dammit!"
Dr. Bright thumped the steering wheel in frustration.
"Any of you know how to fix a car?"
He looked at the team of operatives in the
back seat.
They all shrugged noncommittally.
The only thing worse than wandering into that
fog would be sitting in the broken-down van
watching Tweedledum and Tweedledumber try
to attend to the failing engine.
His private joke almost lifted his mood, but
not quite.
He popped open the door and stepped out into
the cold, damp air.
"Well, figure it out.
I'm gonna take a look around."
Dr. Bright shoved his hands into his pockets,
and, not knowing what might wait on the other
side, began his walk into Silent Hill.
With each step, he ruminated on the events
that had gotten him here.
Where did those guys at the Foundation get
off, disciplining him like an unruly child?
Sure, he liked his pranks.
He enjoyed a good joke, and maybe sometimes
he took it just a little bit too far,
but he'd like to see them confront the existential
dread of immortality without needing a humorous
outlet every now and then.
They'd crack under the pressure without a
release of some kind, so what gave them the
right to put him,
a brilliant if unconventional mind, in some
kind of glorified time out?
He scoffed out loud to himself, and the sound
echoed in the vacant streets.
The sheer emptiness of it all snapped him
out of his self-pity, and for the first time
he looked up to take in his surroundings.
The stubborn fog refused to dissipate, no
matter how far he walked,
but at least he could make out the shapes
of buildings now, of parked cars on the side
of the road.
No, not parked.
Wrecked, abandoned, left to rust.
He scanned the fog for human silhouettes,
listened for voices, for any signs of life.
But there was no one.
He approached a building, and found it dilapidated,
rotted wood collapsing in on itself, windows
cracked, door boarded up tight.
The buildings next to it looked very much
the same.
What the hell?
He was sent to investigate recent disappearances,
but this town looked as if its entire population
had vanished decades ago.
Or, he thought with a small shudder, all decided
to leave in a hurry.
What could have driven them out?
"Okay, that's it.
I'm done," Dr. Bright remarked, turning a
swift 180 degrees and preparing to go back
the way he came.
As he did, though, he froze.
Where there had once been continuous, unbroken
road,
the street now ended in a jagged edge, a deep,
dark chasm the only thing that waited beyond.
It was too broad to jump across, and he couldn't
see another road out of town.
"Hey guys?" he called out, hoping to draw
the attention of one of the men he had left
with the van.
"A little help over here?"
But there was no response.
"Hello?!" he shouted again, louder this time.
When no one answered, he repeated himself
again and again with increasing desperation,
his voice growing hoarse from the effort.
Had they somehow fixed the van and left him
there?
Had they fallen into the chasm where the road
once was and been killed on impact?
There was no rational explanation for what
was at play here, but, as the consciousness
of a man living inside of an ancient amulet
reminded himself,
he very rarely encountered rational things
in his life.
There had to be a way out; he just had to
find it.
If he couldn't go back?
Well, he would just have to keep moving forward.
On through the winding labyrinth of the street,
through the maze of crumbling buildings, looking
for any signs of life.
He followed a natural bend in the road and
suddenly found himself wedged between two
buildings, down a narrow, claustrophobic alley.
It seemed that this place didn't feel much
like playing by the ordinary rules of time
and space.
And while Dr. Bright could usually appreciate
a rulebreaker, being a little rebellious himself,
this uncertainty was putting him on edge.
His breaths came in shallow gasps,
his chest tight with apprehension.
As he turned in a circle, looking for the
best way out, he heard a sound behind him,
the first noise he had heard other than his
own breathing in quite some time.
It was the soft, plodding sound of uneven
footsteps.
Like someone small, walking with a limp.
He whirled around to face the noise and saw
what he might have mistaken for a child, until
he got a proper look at it.
The thing that was steadily approaching him
was small and humanoid in shape,
but that was where the similarities to a human
being ended.
Its skin was a pale, mottled gray, the shade
of a body fished out of a river after weeks
of bloating and decay.
Its mouth was a twisted, gaping hole, more
like a wound than a mouth,
and in place of its eyes were a pair of slits
in the pale flesh.
It stumbled as it walked, like it was still
learning how,
but this childish ineptitude did nothing to
distract from the creature's menace.
As it advanced toward Dr. Bright, he saw the
glint of something metal.
In the creature's gnarled fist, it held a
rusty knife.
As it got closer, it slashed haphazardly in
his direction, and its mouth opened wider
to let out a chilling high-pitched giggle.
This thing was prepared to carve him up and
enjoy every second of the job.
As he took in the sight of the horrible grey
child in front of him, Dr. Bright had been
frozen to the spot,
unable to force his legs to carry him away.
But the sight of the knife, the grim realization
of just exactly what this thing had in store
for him, shocked him back to life.
He grabbed a wooden beam leaning against the
nearest wall and threw it at the little monster,
knocking it onto its back.
It was immobilized just long enough for Dr.
Bright to get his bearings, turn, and run
back toward the wider street.
As he did, he could hear that gleeful laughter
as the creature climbed back to its feet,
and it only pushed him to run faster.
When he could no longer hear the little footsteps
or the warped giggles of the grey child, Dr.
Bright stopped to catch his breath.
So, it seemed like there was life in Silent
Hill after all.
There just wasn't human life.
There was silence for a moment, nothing but
Dr. Bright's heart pounding in his head as
he bent over his knees and silently cursed
himself for not exercising this body more
often.
Then, the shrill cry of an air raid siren
ripped through the foggy air,
and for a moment, his heart stopped.
What the hell did that sound mean?
He stood up, inspecting his surroundings for
signs of danger, for...what?
A tornado?
A bomb?
He wasn't sure, but nothing could have prepared
him for what he saw next.
The entire landscape had shifted around him
in an instant.
He was unsure of how exactly to describe it,
except to say that the world had gotten darker,
more dangerous.
Where the streets had been lit by dim, grey
sunlight filtered through the haze,
there was now darkness, save for an occasional
street lamp with a flickering red bulb.
He couldn't be sure if it was a trick of the
light, but he could swear there was blood
staining the street,
smeared across the brick walls of the buildings
on either side.
The town had been ominous before, but now?
It was like something out of a nightmare.
And all the while, the siren continued to
blare, warning of a danger he could not see.
He needed to find shelter.
That was it.
From what, he didn't know,
but whatever was coming couldn't be good.
Dr. Bright ran to the nearest door, twisting
the knob, trying to yank it open, but it wouldn't
budge.
The hinges were rusted shut, and there was
no time to try and force them open.
He tried another door.
And another.
It was as if the houses knew to try and keep
him out, to keep him exposed and vulnerable
on the outside.
Finally, he reached a two-story house with
peeling white paint and a mahogany door, one
that looked so familiar but that he couldn't
quite place.
When he turned the knob, the door creaked
open with ease, and he quickly raced inside,
slammed the door shut behind him, and locked
it.
As Dr. Bright slumped against the door, overtaken
with exhaustion, an intrusive thought made
his stomach drop.
Was he alone in this house?
Had he really found shelter,
or had he just shut himself inside with something
even worse than what waited out there?
In the silence, he could swear he heard the
quiet thumping of a pulse, but he couldn't
tell if it was his own or the house's beating
heart.
He couldn't just stay standing here, dreaming
up all the horrors that might be waiting.
He needed to gather data, investigate his
surroundings, and come up with potential solutions.
He needed to be a scientist.
On unsteady legs, Dr. Bright began to walk
the halls of the house, taking in his surroundings
properly for the first time.
It was dusty and dark, a place left vacant
for quite some time, but there were signs
of a life once lived within the house's walls.
A rocking horse in the corner, a shelf full
of well-worn books.
The titles scratched an itch in his brain,
memories he hadn't touched in decades.
Strange, that so many of the books in this
house would remind him of the pages he once
flipped through, staying inside to read while
his brother played in the yard outside.
His brother…
Dr. Bright swallowed the lump in his throat
at the thought of TJ.
No use going down that path, not right now.
He continued his walk through the house, taking
in the cobwebs, the couch covered with plastic,
the coffee table, and the tv set.
Along the hall leading to the bathroom, there
were rows of family pictures hanging in neat
little frames.
He stopped to take a look, wondering what
sort of family had once lived here.
As his eyes fell on the first photograph,
his blood turned to ice in his veins.
A boy looked out from within the frame, a
familiar boy with a mop of red hair, a freckled
nose, and kind, smiling eyes.
"No..."
Dr. Bright whispered to himself.
But there was no denying it.
It was TJ.
His brother,
somehow, looking at him from inside a photograph
in an abandoned house in Silent Hill.
Next, there was a photo of TJ and an older
man.
Dr. Bright's stomach turned.
Their father.
Every photograph was of his family, the family
he would never know again, not the way they
were.
And there, in one photo in the middle, TJ
and his father were joined by another figure,
one with the face scratched out of the picture.
He knew, though he couldn't see for certain,
that it was him, removed from the family photo
by force.
The bond between them all forever broken.
TJ's eyes in the picture seemed filled with
tears, heartbroken.
His father glowered out of the frame at him,
pure hatred in his gaze.
He couldn't look anymore and turned away.
On the opposite wall, another photograph of
TJ was waiting.
Dr. Bright felt bile rising in his throat.
He recognized this photo, he saw it sometimes
when he closed his eyes at night.
It was a picture taken with SCP-978, the Desire
Camera,
the anomalous camera that reveals its subject's
innermost desires.
In the photo, TJ's hands were pressed to the
lens, like an animal clawing at the boundaries
of its cage.
His eyes were filled with tears, spilling
over and streaming down his cheeks.
And his mouth was wide open in an endless
scream of fear and agony.
This, Dr. Bright knew, was the wordless scream
inside his brother's mind at all times, after
so much testing with the Foundation had destroyed
him.
"I tried to help you..." he whispered to the
picture.
"I did what I could to, take the pain away..."
He trailed off, the words dying in his throat,
as the sound of a heavy, rattling breath came
from the room at the end of the hall.
It was a thick, wheezing sound, like a death
rattle a dozen times over.
He didn't want to see what was making the
noise, but, as if in a trance, he found his
feet carrying him toward it.
He crossed the threshold of what should have
been the kitchen, but instead found himself
in a dimly lit hospital.
The air smelled of formaldehyde and dried
vomit, the steady beep of a heart monitor
joining the chorus of heavy, agonizing breathing.
At the end of the long hall there was one
single room, the door standing slightly ajar.
With slow, agonizing steps, Dr. Bright approached
the room.
The breathing grew louder and louder, the
beep of the heart monitor almost deafening
in his ears.
He could barely separate the strange breathing
from his own, finding his breaths coming in
time with the painful, rattling sound.
He pushed the door open and saw a figure lying
in a hospital bed.
It was once human, but it could only be described
now as a conglomerate of disease and pain.
On top of the figure's head, thinning in patches
but still recognizable, was a shock of red
hair.
"No...TJ...no-" Dr. Bright's voice broke off
in a sob at the sight.
The thing that was once his brother turned,
seeking the sound of his voice though he could
not see.
"Isn't this what you wanted?"
A low voice rumbled behind him.
Dr. Bright whirled around to see a dark shadow,
red eyes glowing in the low light.
It moved like a wisp of black smoke, but he
knew that voice well enough to tell just who
it was.
His father.
"You let them do this to him."
"I didn't...I didn't mean for this to happen..."
Dr. Bright stammered.
"You didn't care!"
the demon father roared, and the lightbulb
above their heads flared and burst, sending
shards of glass scattering everywhere.
"All he ever did was help people, to heal
pain.
And all you ever did was cause it."
Dr. Bright found the strength to move, running
through the doorway, sending the shape of
his father in every direction as the smell
of sulfur and blood filled his nose.
"I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry."
He wept as he ran, hearing his father's agonized
cries,
his brother's labored breathing, as he tore
back down the hospital hall.
As he did, hands began to reach through the
walls, the floor, the ceiling.
They were rotting, flesh gone green and stiff.
Arms followed the hands, then shoulders, then
faces.
He recognized D-Class uniforms, lab coats,
face after familiar face.
Everyone who had ever worn the amulet, he
realized with a sudden wave of nausea.
Everyone whose body he had taken, who he had
killed so that he could live.
"This is what you do."
He could hear his father's voice just behind
him, the curls of black smoke nipping at his
heels.
"What kind of creature kills to live?
Something that deserves to die.
But you can't, can you?
You're a parasite, sucking all of the good
and the life from this world until it's an
empty husk, just like you."
The living graveyard of victims reached for
Dr. Bright, tearing at his clothes as he passed
them.
There were so many...he'd never realized how
many until he saw them all lined up like this.
"I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry," he said to every face he passed,
but there was no forgiveness in their dead
eyes.
His father's voice fell silent, but there
was no reprieve.
Instead, there was the sound of heavy footsteps
pursuing him, the grating shriek of a large
bladed weapon dragging along the ground.
Dr. Bright glanced over his shoulder and saw
a massive, hulking figure, like a man but
with a jagged metal pyramid covering his head.
He was clad in blood-stained clothing, and
approaching Dr. Bright with the casual menace
of something that had killed endless times
before, and was ready to do it again.
It didn't care to chase him, it knew it would
eventually catch up.
As he looked at the figure, it began to warp,
to change.
It morphed into something else...something
he recognized.
A man, with black hair and grey eyes that
revealed nothing but cold malice.
A body, covered in tattoos of the arcane and
the occult, of merciless grinning faces belonging
to ancient monsters.
And in his hand, a long bladed weapon, a curved
sword perfectly engineered for battle.
It was impossible, he should be contained,
but there he was.
SCP-076-2, looking at Dr. Bright the same
way he had on the day he had first worn the
amulet.
The day he became an abomination.
The sound of his brother's breathing grew
louder, his fathers voice bellowing in his
mind,
and he felt the grasp of the fallen Foundation
employees at his back.
It was all too much, too many reminders of
every failure, every hurt.
Dr. Bright collapsed to his knees, and bared
his neck to Able in submission.
"You're right.
I should be punished.
I've done nothing but hurt, and kill, and
destroy everything I touch.
Just punish me.
Please...I'm begging you."
Then, something Dr. Bright never could have
expected.
The figure that looked like Able but couldn't
be began to laugh, a cruel, hollow sound.
"No."
It said, in a voice that sounded like a chorus
of hundreds.
"We will release you.
Nothing we can do here will ever be worse
than the eternity of torment that stretches
before you.
Good luck to you...Dr. Bright."
Jack Bright let out a wail of agony, reaching
out to Able with pleading hands as the entity
turned
and slowly walked away, leaving him there
alone with the hell that was his thoughts.
Then, everything faded to black.
"Dr. Bright?
Dr. Bright?!"
The sound of one of the team members brought
Dr. Bright back to consciousness, and he opened
his eyes.
He was lying on his side on the same road
he had walked along before, right next to
the sign welcoming the group to Silent Hill.
"You're all...still here?" he asked, weakly.
"What do you mean?"
The man looked puzzled.
"We parked the van, you got out, you fell
down, and we've been trying to wake you up."
"How long was I out...?"
Dr. Bright's vision swam as he tried to wrap
his mind around the information.
"I dunno, about ten minutes?"
Now go check out “What if You Were Related
to Dr Bright?
- SCP-590 - He Feels Your Pain” and “SCP
Edition - Weirdest Things on Amazon - Dr Bright's
Great Idea!”
for more funny and tragic tales from the book
of Dr. Bright!